oh my god you see that guy over there  yeah that's my class  [Music]  surround this gym trying to recruit  people to be an escort no  definitely let's wishin Network sometime  so grab the five here you go ten reps  okay here we go one Starbucks  maybe I've gotta say I didn't really use  a green tea you know what can you just  take a lot of mine okay so put a squad  yeah I know how to do perfect all right  cool study personal training for that  Wow  [Music]  that's not you should have the pressure  on your heels that was loose last one  give me three more three more I feel  good thanks we'll see you tomorrow oh my  gosh I forgot my key yeah Gloria Lori  lower left  oh I'm sorry No  let's the stretch starts maybe later all  right  [Music]  [Music]